النشاط الدبلوماسي الاكبر في تاريخ الصين
مع العرب هكذا تصف بيجين زياره الرئيس
جيجن بينج للرياض دفعه واحده يلتقي الرجل
16 من قاده البلدان العربيه وممثلهم في
قمم ثلاثه قمه صينيه سعوديه وقمه صينيه
خليجيه سبقتها قمه لدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي وقمه صينيه عربيه
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه تحت قياده فخامه
الرئيس يجيبهم قصه نجاح تتجلى في مكانه
الصين الرائده الاقتصاديه العالميه وتولد
اهميه قصوى لرفع مستوى الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع جمهوريه فلسطين الشعبيه
بهذه الجهود لتعظيم مكاسب هذه الشراك كما
تتطلع دون مجلس التعاون وتبادل الخبرات
مستوى جديد للعلاقات وما بدا كلمه السر في
تصريحات جيم بنك يفتح بها الباب لعلاقه
تتجاوز افق التبادل التجاري المتقدم اصلا
بميزان يتجاوز 330 مليار دولار مع مجمل
الدول العربيه كلمه السر تبحث عن مساحات
شركه تتيح حضور صينيا اكبر في المنطقه
بمعان اكثر وهي تواصل ما تعرف بمبادره
الحزام والطريق
على الجانبين الصيني والعربي ان يتمسكها
بالاستقلاليه والمصالح المشتركه ونحن ندعم
جهود الدول العربيه لاستكشاف الطرق
التنمويه التي تتماشى مع ظروفها الوطنيه
وتساعدها في التحكم في مستقبلها وان يكون
مصيرها في ايدها الصين تحرص على تعليق
الثقه الاستراتيجيه المتبادله مع الجانب
العربي وذلك للحفاظ على سياده البلدان
وكرامتها الوطنيه على الجانبين التمسك
بمبدا عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
وبالحقوق المشروعه
ولنميه
رؤيه ثانيه لا يمكن عزلهما عن طرفي الزمان
والمكان الصين منافسه الولايات المتحده
الابرز تزور الخليج في زمن تزداد فيه حده
التجاذبات العالميه في ملفات عده ابرزها
سقوط الطاقه
تختتم زياره الرئيس الصيني للرياض بعد قمه
من ثلاث تحاول فتحه افاق ابعد للعلاقه قمم
وجدت اصدارها عالميا وفتحت باب التساؤلات
عما سيكون بعدها عدنان ولينا الجزيره
الرياض